as you no doubt know lately american
consumers have been dealing with supply
chain issues that have kept many
overseas products off store shelves but
while we may not think about it those
same supply issues flow the other way
too and in japan that has meant a
shortage of an american grown staple
that defines fast food giving rise to
some creative solutions lucy craft has
more on how one fast food chain is
answering its short supply of spuds
burger king which operates over 150
restaurants in japan found itself in a
pickle last spring supply chain snafus
left it with a dwindling stock of french
fries
so until new supplies finally arrive
customers are being asked to swap out
fries for something japan has no
shortage of ramen
noodles burger king calls this it's
almost potato set burgers with a side of
crunchy ramen noodles they're nice and
salty but without that hot greasy aroma
it just ain't the same
customers grabbing lunch recently seem
to agree
i'd be sad without fries this office
worker said i always get fries with my
burger
this customer said if burger king had
only crunchy ramen maybe i just go to
mcdonald's burger king says its unusual
offerings have earned it such devoted
fans many have given up fries as a show
of loyalty
besides crunchy ramen other french fry
options were considered like broiled
squid apple pie and even boiled ramen
noodles
burger king isn't the only fast food
chain grappling with spud shortfalls
last winter rival mcdonald's was forced
to ration fries and potato nuggets for
nearly a month
japan depends on american growers from
most of the frozen potatoes processed
into french fries and sold here at major
chains
and unpredictable weather global
conflicts and logistics woes could cook
up another french fry emergency
for cbs saturday morning lucy kraft
tokyo
i know that little boy is
they have potato
potato tater tots
tater tots are not you mean at
mcdonald's i've never seen them here i
haven't either tater tots not not a bad
standing but it's still potato i mean
i've studied this scientifically nothing
yes i've done it officially nothing yeah
nothing can properly stand in
front of an accompaniment to a burger
like fries
certainly not squid
no or boiled ramen no at least you're
trying with the fried parsley yeah the
crispy the crispy i would put it inside
the sandwich
mash it and then have it i kind of
that's a good idea it is a good idea
yeah can we get fries i have good ideas
fries please anyone